digamos que tengo una rampa hecha de
hielo más o menos algo así aunque quizás
no es muy preciso mi dibujo pero la idea
es que se entienda lo siguiente tengo
esta rampa hecha de hielo y digamos que
en realidad es un plano inclinado y con
una inclinación de 30 grados ok entonces
vamos a hacer todo todo este vídeo
suponiendo que todo está hecho de hielo
para así poder pensar que tenemos una
fricción despreciable ok entonces ya que
tenemos esta inclinación de 30 grados
aunque y entonces ahora vamos a pensar
que encima hay un bloque de hielo
digamos aquí hay un bloque de hielo que
además brilla como como brilla el hielo
ahí está nuestro bloque de hielo y que
está brillando como justamente como
brilla el hielo y digamos que este
bloque de aquí tiene una masa una masa
de
es kilogramos muy bien entonces 10
kilogramos para que las las operaciones
y las cuentas sean sencillas así que
vamos a pensar qué es lo que va a
ocurrir y por supuesto cuando pensamos
que es lo que va a ocurrir estamos
hablando de cuáles son las fuerzas que
interactúan sobre este bloque de hielo
aunque ya entonces vamos a suponer que
la gravedad que influye sobre este
bloque es el digamos la gravedad
terrestre y que sabemos que éste es una
fuerza es una fuerza que va del de la
masa hacia el centro de la tierra muy
bien
déjenme pintar lo mejor
ahí lo tienen ok entonces digamos que
esta es la fuerza de gravedad y está la
podemos calcular fácilmente nosotros
sabemos que la fuerza de gravedad es
masa por 9.8 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado que es la constante
gravitacional de la gravedad terrestre
verdad sin embargo la masa es de 10
kilogramos por lo tanto 10 por 9.8
serían 98 newtons en dirección digamos
hacia abajo déjenme hacerlo con cuidado
si nosotros nosotros sabemos calcular
esta fuerza que son 10 kilogramos 10
kilogramos por 9.8 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado verdad esta es la
aceleración y esto lo estamos pensando
digamos hacia abajo verdad y cuando digo
hacia abajo me refiero a hacia el centro
de la tierra verdad estamos pensando en
esta dirección justamente entonces 10
kilogramos por 9.8 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado
10 por 9.8 nos dan 98 y metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado por kilogramos nos
da justamente newtons entonces tenemos
nosotros
estos newtons 98 newtons ahora vamos a
descomponer la fuerza de gravedad en su
componente digamos perpendicular y dejen
medio una vez pintarlo la componente
perpendicular digamos más o menos hacia
acá
ahí tienen esta componente perpendicular
y también descomponer en la componente
paralela paralela déjenme pintarlo bien
esta componente paralela al plano y
entonces este de aquí es una componente
perpendicular muy bien entonces en el
vídeo anterior nosotros vimos cómo
calcular justamente las magnitudes de
estos dos nosotros de hecho vimos que
como se calculaban esta esta esta
componente perpendicular esencialmente
eran la masa o bueno la magnitud de ésta
de esta fuerza que son 98 newtons por el
coseno del ángulo por el coseno de 30
grados ok esto es por supuesto son
newtons y este de acá abajo digamos lo
que sería la componente paralela son 98
por el seno ahora sería seno
seno de nuestro ángulo que son 30 grados
muy bien entonces de estos sólo tienes
que recordar que estos de aquí se
obtienen de trigonometría básica verdad
no lo voy a no voy a repetir como lo
obtuvimos porque de hecho lo hicimos en
el vídeo anterior ahí está simplemente
utilizamos las las funciones
trigonométricas y trigonometría básica
para poder encontrar la magnitud de
estos dos componentes muy bien entonces
simplemente es de las funciones
trigonométricas sencillas ahora bien la
pregunta es cuánto valen estas funciones
trigonométricas en 30 grados y esto es
algo que cuando uno estudia el
trigonometría prácticamente se lo tiene
uno que memorizar esto de aquí vale raíz
de tres entre dos mientras que este de
abajo vale un medio y realmente a lo
mejor si no te lo memorizar lo puedes
deducir tú por tu propia cuenta o
incluso puedes ver los vídeos que hemos
hecho aquí en la canaca de mi sobre
sobre funciones trigonométricas
esto lo obtienes de estudiar los
triángulos 30 60 90 o también puedes
utilizar triángulos equiláteros hay
varias formas de hacerlo puedes checar
lo por tu cuenta entonces si ya tenemos
cuánto vale esto entonces podemos
obtener ya una expresión adecuada para
la magnitud de esta componente entonces
tendremos 98 raíz de 3 entre 2 cuantos
98 entre 2 esos son 49 por la raíz de 3
y estos son newtons y vamos a decir que
apuntan hacia adentro hacia adentro
ok vamos a decir vamos hacia adentro del
plano y tenemos que poner la dirección
porque son son vectores verdad entonces
digo no se les para para ir simplemente
sentando ideas vamos a escribirlo así
para no tener que estar escribiendo
vectores justamente y este de aquí este
que tenemos abajo y de hecho sabemos que
es exactamente este vector verdad este
vector que estoy pintando ahora acá
arriba simplemente por propiedades de
paralelismo verdad entonces este vector
de acá arriba es tiene una magnitud
déjeme ponerlo así tiene una magnitud de
vamos a de hecho escribirlo
este es el la componente paralelo a la
superficie es de 49 newtons y vamos a
decir que es paralelo hacia abajo
paralelo
digamos hacia abajo porque porque va
hacia abajo verdad hacia abajo
del plano ok vamos a dejarlo así del
plano que en realidad es de la
superficie del plano pero vamos a vamos
a dejarlo así muy bien muy bien
entonces todo esto que obtuvimos fue
porque este ángulo valía 30 grados y que
vimos en el vídeo anterior que era
exactamente igual a este otro ahora
pensemos en lo siguiente cuando uno deja
un bloque de hielo sobre un plano de
hecho de hecho también de hielo de hecho
esto es hielo verdad entonces cuando uno
deja este bloque encima de este plano
uno nunca uno que esperaría observar
bueno lo que podemos ver es que este
este bloque no va no va digamos ni a
flotar ni a lo que voy es lo siguiente
si no hubiera alguna otra fuerza que
fuera en la dirección perpendicular a
este plano entonces este bloque se
seguiría acelerando hacia el interior
del plano sin
eso no ocurre verdad quiere decir que
debe haber alguna fuerza aquí que sea
también perpendicular al plano que
contrarrestre que contrarreste perdón la
componente perpendicular de la gravedad
sobre el plano ya este es al que le
llamamos la fuerza normal y debe ser de
la misma magnitud debe ser de 49 raíz de
3 newtons pero aquí estamos pensando que
va hacia afuera hacia afuera de la
superficie muy bien en esa dirección
entonces esto es porque nuestro bloque
no puede seguir acelerando hacia el
centro digamos o en dirección hacia
dentro del de la superficie de este
plano y entonces por eso es que
necesitamos esta fuerza normal que la
contrarreste que lo podemos pensar
simplemente como una fuerza de contacto
y que de hecho ya hablamos un poco de
ello
vídeos anteriores ahora bien si no
tenemos algo digamos que como no tenemos
fricción verdad estamos suponiendo que
no hay fricción sin fricción y eso y por
eso es que nos tomamos el hielo verdad
porque de esta forma el hielo tiene una
fricción tan pequeña que la podemos
despreciar entonces si no hay fricción
nos queda únicamente esta fuerza que va
en dirección paralela del de la
superficie del plano entonces esta
fuerza sabemos que provoca una
aceleración y de hecho lo que sabemos es
que la fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración entonces si yo quiero
conocer la aceleración que provoca
simplemente tengo que dividir de ambos
lados entre la masa y me queda la
aceleración entonces yo tengo aquí en mi
fuerza
si ahora divido entre la masa que son 10
kilogramos y es kilogramos si divido
entre 10 kilogramos de ambos lados
entonces lo que me queda es
la aceleración que son 49 newtons / 10
kilogramos esto es 4.9 newtons /
kilogramos son metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado y ahí tenemos la aceleración
que también tiene una dirección verdad
digamos que va paralelo
hacia abajo la aceleración es paralela
más bien hacia abajo
de de la superficie más bien hacia abajo
d
la superficie muy bien y entonces ahí
tenemos ya más o menos resuelto este
problema de hecho tenemos bien resuelto
este problema verdad si sólo hubiera una
componente perpendicular entonces él se
aceleraría al centro del plano pero no
verdad ahí se encuentra sobre este plano
y por eso es que necesitamos de la
existencia de esta fuerza normal que es
la fuerza de contacto ahora bien como no
hay fricción este bloque de hielo
acelera hacia abajo con esta magnitud
verdad 4.9 en esa dirección ahora te
dejaré ahí a que pienses lo que veremos
en el siguiente vídeo si no se moviera
este este bloque digamos si no acelerará
cuál sería la fuerza que lo mantiene en
un estado estático piensa sobre ello y
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo